Hi.
My name is Andrew Gerrand.
And today I'm going to show you
how to get started with
the Go programming language,
but first some background.
Go is a new general purpose
programming language.
It was designed to give the
performance benefits of a
compiled, statically type
language with the workflow of
a scripting language.
It incorporates concurrency
primitives that make it easy
to write programs for today
asynchronous networked world.
Also great care was taken in
Go's design to be clear and
consistent in the language
features and
its standard libraries.
All this combined to make
programming in Go to both
productive and fun.
Go began as a 20 Percent
project among
some Googlers in 2007.
In November 2009 it was released
to the world as an
open source project, which
attracted hundreds of
contributors from the open
source community.
In March 2012, we released
Go Version 1.
A specification of the language
and libraries will be
supported for years to come.
In the tutorial today,
we're going to learn
about Go version 1.
So let's get started.
The first thing you must
do is install Go.
You can install the Go compiler
on most popular
operating systems and process
architectures.
I won't go through the
installation process now as it
varies from platform
to platform.
Just visit golang.org and follow
the instructions there
to get started.
So now that we have a Go
installation, let's test that
everything is working.
Put this code into a file
named hello.go.
And then on the command line use
the Go tool to compile and
run that program.
You should see the greeting
fellow gopher.
This indicates that the
installation was successful
and that your Go compiler
is working properly.
The Go tool that we've just use
is the standard tool for
building, testing, and
installing Go programs.
As we just saw, we could use
it to compile and run a
program in an ad hoc
kind of way.
You can also use it
to run tests.
This command line here runs the
tests and the archives it
package for the standard
library.
These two commands will build
and format the files in the
current directory.
And it can also be used to fetch
packages from remote
repositories.
This command line fetches the
web socket package from the
go.net subrepository.
The Go tool is a zero
configuration tool that
derives all it's Go instructions
from the Go tool
code itself.
There's no need to write and
maintain build scripts when
using the Go tool.
But for this to work, some
prescribed directory structure
is necessary.
We call this a workspace.
A workspace is a directory
which has three
subdirectories, the bin
subdirectory for containing
executable binaries, the package
subdirectory for
compiled object files, and the
source subdirectory which
contains your Go source code.
The first two directories are
generally maintained by the Go
tool itself, while the third
directory is the hierarchy
that you will maintain
yourself.
So let's create a
workspace now.
I usually use the name Go Code
in my home directory as the
root of my workspace, but you
can choose anything that's the
most convenient to you.
We create the source directory
ourselves because that's the
one that we're going to
maintain, but the bin and
package subdirectories will be
maintained by the Go tool.
Now tell the Go tool where the
workspace is by setting the
GOPATH environment variable.
And you might also want to add
the GOPATH bin subdirectory to
your system path.
Now you need to choose a
namespace in which your
personal code is
going to live.
I use the root of my Github
account, github.com/nf.
That can also be used with Go
Get to automatically fetch
these packages.
And now I'm going to create a
Hello directory inside my
namespace and copy our Hello
World program there.
And now I can use the Go install
command with the full
path of my new package to
build and install the
executable to my GOPATH
bin subdirectory.
And there I see my greeting.
So let's talk about the project
we're going to do today.
Our project is going to be a
command line tool for fetching
and displaying most recent
headlines from the golang page
on the popular link aggregation
site Reddit.
The program will make an HTTP
request to the Reddit API,
decode the JSON response into a
Go data structure, and then
print each links title, URL,
and the number of comments.
To get started, let's create a
path for our directory inside
our namespace called Reddit.
This is where we're going to
put our Go source files.
This is the beginning of our
program, and it makes an HTTP
request to the Reddit API and
copies the response to your
console standard output.
We'll take the contents of this
file and put it inside a
file named main.go inside
the Reddit directory.
There's a lot of code there.
So let's walk through the
program piece by piece.
Our program begins with
a package statement.
All Go code belongs to a
package, and Go programs begin
with function main inside
package main.
Since this is an executable
program, we put
it in package main.
Next comes an import
declaration.
The declaration specifies
the file's dependencies.
Each string is an import path
which instructs the Go tools
where it find the required
package.
These packages here are all
from the standard library.
Next is a function
declaration.
Our main function takes
no arguments
and returns no value.
We'll see some more complex
function declarations later.
The first one of the function
makes a function call to the
HTTP packages Get function.
The Get function returns two
values, an HTTP response, and
an error value.
Yeah, that's right.
Go functions can return
multiple values.
We assign the response and the
error value to two new
variables, resp and err.
Next we check the err value
to see whether it is nil.
Nil is the zero value
for an error.
If any error has occurred, the
err value will not be nil.
If an error didn't occur,
it will be nil.
So if an error has occurred, we
use the log package's fatal
function to print that error
to standard error and then
exit the program.
After checking the error of the
request, we need to check
to the successful HTTP request
returned and status OK.
So we check the response object
status code field to
test whether it is at
200 OK response.
If not, we'll call log.fatal
again, this time to print the
response string to standard
output before exiting.
Next we use the io package's
copy function to copy the
response body to the
standard output.
The io copy function takes a
reader value and a writer
value and copies the contents
of the reader to the writer.
The response body implements
io.Reader, while the OS
send-it out represents
io.Writer.
We'll see other examples of
this interface later on.
So let's take a look at that
program in action now.
So there's our JSON blob.
You can see that it's pretty
inscrutable, so we need to
decode it before we can
do something with it.
So the Reddit API returns JSON
in this kind of form.
It has a root object with a data
field, containing another
object with a children field,
containing a list of objects
which each have a data field,
and finally we have the object
with the actual post data.
So it's kind of deeply
nested in that way.
The way Go's JSON package
works is that it decodes
JSON-encoded data into native Go
data structures by matching
field names.
And so to decode this response,
we need to set up
some Go data types
that resemble the
JSON response object.
First of all, let's start
with this piece of data.
We define an item struct which
is named Item, which has two
fields, title and URL, which
are both strings.
The JSON value when decoding
this inner value will assign
the title field to Title and
the URL field to our
object's URL field.
And now to represent the rest of
the object, we declare this
response struct.
And the response struct contains
one field of data,
which is itself a struct, which
contains another field
of children, which is
a slice of structs.
A slice in Go is like
a list or an array.
But we won't be talking about
slices in detail in this talk.
Each slice contains a single
field data, which contains an
item value.
And so you can sort of see how
this data structure and the
item structure inside it
resemble our JSON.
To decode the response, instead
of just copying the
response body to standard
output, we're going to create
a response object and store a
pointer to that object in
[INAUDIBLE].
And then we use the JSON new
decoder function to create a
decoder that reads from
the response body.
And then we invoke the decode
method on our decoder, passing
in the pointer to
our response.
This makes the decoder read
from the response body,
decoding all of the JSON fields
into a response object.
Finally, we store the decode
method's error value in our
err variable.
Now we need to print the data.
To do that, we use a full loop
to iterate over our children's
slice, printing each child's
title in turn.
This full loop uses a range
clause, which is a kind of
shorthand for iterating over
internal data types such as
slices and maps.
For each iteration of the loop,
we assign a value from
the child slice to this
child variable.
This underscore here signifies
that I'm ignoring a value.
If I had put a variable name
there, it would be assigned to
the index of the slice at each
part through the loop.
Let's look at that action.
And now we see a
list of titles.
So now we have a program
that works.
But it's just one function,
and so it's not very
extendable and maintainable.
As the scope of our program
grows, structure and
modularity will become
more important.
What if want to check several
subreddit or share this
functionality with
another program?
To address these concerns let's
create another function
named Get that take the name of
the subreddit, makes an API
call, and returns the items
for that subreddit and an
error value.
This function definition here,
Get, takes a string named
Reddit which will specify the
name of our subreddit and
returns a slice of items
and an error value.
So let's walk through
our new function.
It begins by constructing the
URL that we're going to make
the request to, using the
S printer function.
The S printer function takes a
format string, in this case
the bulk of our string with a
percent S where we want to
substitute in the reddit.
And then the next argument
is our reddit string.
So if reddit was golang
this would be
reddit.com/r/golang.json.
And we store this in
the URL variable.
Then we make our HTTP request as
before and check the error.
But notice that this time
instead of calling log.fatal
to bail out of the program we
want to return the error, and
so we return a nil value for
our item slice, indicating
that there are no items to
return, and our err value as
our error value.
But notice that when we handle
the response code later on,
our status field is actually a
string, not an error value.
To convert this string into an
error value, we used the
err.new function.
After making the HTTP request,
we need to be
sure to clean up.
We didn't do this previously
because all of the action was
taking place in the
main function.
And we know that when the
function returns the program
shuts down, cleaning up any open
TCP sockets and so on.
But in this case, with our Get
function, it could be used in
the context of the
bigger program.
And so we need to make sure to
clean up the HTTP request when
the function exits.
We do this by calling the close
method on the response
body, which shuts down the
underlying TCP connection.
And this defer keyword here
ensures that regardless of
where the function exists,
whether it's on a bad status
code or on a bad JSON decode
or on a successful request,
that this function call
is made after
the function returns.
Next we prepare our item
slice to return.
We do this by initializing a
new slice of items with the
make function with the same
length as the children in our
response body.
Then we iterate through the
response body assigning each
child's data item to the
corresponding field in our
item slice.
And finally, we return our
items at a nil value to
signify success.
Now let's use the Get function
in our main function.
So I throw away most of the
contents of the main function
and replace it with a single
call to Get, passing in the
string golang to signify
the go subreddit.
We then assign the returned
items to a new items variable
and the error to the
err variable.
And in our full loop at bottom,
we now just iterate
over the item slice.
And for each item, we print
the item's title.
But we're only printing the
titles isn't very helpful.
Let's address that.
Go's [INAUDIBLE] package knows
how to print all of the
built-in types, but it can
also be told how to print
user-defined types.
When you pass a value to
[INAUDIBLE] print, it checks
to see if that value implements
the [INAUDIBLE]
Stringer interface.
The Stringer interface it
contains one method, string,
which returns a string.
And so any type that implements
that string method
implements a Stringer.
And the [INAUDIBLE] package will
use that method to format
values of those types.
So let's add a string method
to item types so that our
items are printed
out more nicely.
A method declaration is just
like a function declaration,
but the receiver comes first.
In this case, we specify
the receiver item.
And inside the function, it
will be identified by i.
This i is similar to this or
self in, say, JavaScript or
Python, except in Go you're
encouraged to use a short name
that's evocative of the type
that it describes.
Inside the function, we use the
S printer function from
the [INAUDIBLE] package to print
the title, a new line,
followed by the URL.
Now when we want to print the
item, we just pass the item
into the [INAUDIBLE]
function.
So let's take this
a step further.
One way to judge the quality
or lack thereof of a
particular link is to look
at the discussion
that surrounds it.
So let's display the number of
comments alongside each link.
To do this, we need to get the
number of comments from the
Reddit API and store it
in our item struct.
So we'll add these comment
field, which is an integer
type, to our item struct.
But notice that comment is not
the same as the num_comment
field in the Reddit
API response.
Underscores are kind of
unsightly in Go, and we don't
tend to use them.
So what I'll do is used what's
known as a struct tag to
instruct the JSON package that
I'm looking for the field
num_comment in my JSON for this
particular struct field.
This means that when decoding
it will look for noncomments
instead of comments.
And went encoding it will put
it into a num_comment field.
And now we can make a string
method a little more complex.
This string method now uses a
switch statement to switch on
the number of comments and show
nothing if there are zero
comments, to show one comment
if there is one comment, and
to show the number of comments
if there's more than one.
Notice that unlike many
languages, Go switch
statements do not fall
through by default.
Now when we run our program,
we should see a nicely
formatted list of links.
And now we see each title, and
the ones with comment have the
number of comments after them.
Let's package this up so that we
can share with other people
because it's useful code.
Reddit is a good name for our
package, and so let's keep it
for the package and move our
main function elsewhere.
Create a subdirectory inside
your Reddit directory named
Geddit and copy your
main.go file there.
Now let's rename the main.go
file inside the Reddit
directory to reddit.go
as this will
become our package source.
Now let's modify the reddit.go
file to be a Go package.
First, change the package
statement at the top of
reddit.go from package main
to package reddit.
It's just a convention that the
package name be the same
as the last element of the
import path so that it's not
surprising when you import a
package and then find that
it's imported under
a different name.
The only requirement here is
that it is not package main
as, again, that signifies
an executable command.
Next I need to remove the main
function from reddit.go and
any unused package imports.
Our reddit.go file now looks
like this in the overview.
Note that I've omitted the
bodies of each of these
declarations.
We have our import block, the
response struct, the item
struct, its string method, and
finally or Get method.
And let's edit the
geddit/main.go file to remove
all of those other declarations
that are now in
the reddit package and
prefix the Get
invocation with the reddit.
Now let's compile and install
our Geddit program, which will
automatically compile
and store our reddit
package if need be.
In running it, we should see the
same behaviors as before.
Now let's talk about
documentation.
The Go distribution provides
a tool called godoc for
displaying Go documentation.
Just as the Go tool reads Go
source files that derive build
instructions, godoc reads source
files to derive Go
documentation.
It's much easier to keep
documentation in sync when the
documentation and the code
that it describes
live in the same file.
So let's look at the
documentation
for our reddit package.
You can see our type
declarations, the method
declaration, and our Get
function declaration,
but not much else.
Let's rectify this
by adding some
documentation to our package.
The one big thorn the sticks out
in that documentation is
the response type.
There's no need for to be part
of a public interface.
And so we can hide it by
renaming it to response with a
lowercase r.
This in because in Go top-level
declarations the
begin with an upper case letter
are considered exported
and therefore visible
outside the package.
All the other names re private
and inaccessible to code
outside the package.
And now to document the
remaining visible names, we
just add a comment directly
above the declarations.
So our item struct has
this short string.
Item describes a reddit item.
And our Get function
has this string.
Get Fetch is the most recent
items posted to
the specified subreddit.
But the most important piece
of documentation is our
package doc, which
we add directly
above the package clause.
We won't worry about documenting
the string method
as all Go programs should
know what that does.
Now let's take a look
at the godoc output
for our revised package.
You'll see that includes our
package doc at the top, and
then our Get function here
describes itself, and the same
goes for item struct.
Notice that the response value
is now an internal detail and
doesn't get presented to
the user in godoc.
So now we're ready to share
our work with the world.
To do this, we'll prepare a
source repository and push it
to my Github account.
The first thing you should do
is add a copyright notice to
each file, and you should also
choose your preferred license
and put it in the license
file in the root of your
repository.
I'm not going to do this now,
but I trust you can figure out
how to do it on your own.
Next I'm going to initialization
my source
control repository with git init
and then prepare a commit
with my reddit.go and
geddit/main.go file.
And then I'll commit that.
Then I'll add a remote
identifying the Github
repository.
And then push my master
branch to that remote.
And that's worked.
Now to test that I've done
everything correctly, I'm
going to reinstall my package
using the Go Get command.
So first I'll blow away
everything that I've just
done, a little nerve wracking.
And you'll see that I only have
my Hello package inside
my namespace now.
And then with the Go Get
command, I can fetch and
install my package
and command.
So this command will check out
my reddit repository and then
build and install the reddit
package followed by building
and installing the geddit
executable.
And as with all good Unix
commands, the Go command says
nothing if it succeeds.
So now I should be able to type
Geddit and see the output
of my program.
The Go Get command can fetch
code from a range of popular
code hosting sites as well as
any arbitrary Get material
subversion of [INAUDIBLE]
repository.
All you need to do is provide
to the repository URL on the
Go Get command line.
So here are some ideas as to how
you can take this further
in your own time.
You might want to implement a
command line interface to
specify the subreddits or
subreddits to query.
You could expand the reddit
package to cover more of the
reddit API such as
user information.
And you could learn about Go's
concurrency primitives and use
them to perform multiple
requests in parallel.
The first stop for anyone new
to Go should be the tour at
tour.golang.org.
It's an interactive web-based
toward the language that lets
you play with the language
right from your browser.
Next visit golang.org/doc for
a wealth of documentation,
articles, tutorials, code
walks, and so on.
And finally, the standard
library reference at
golang.org/pkg is an
indispensable reference to any
Go programmer.
That's it for me.
Thanks for watching.